bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir le patron des députés communistes
bonsoir André chasseg merci merci d'être
notre grand témoins ce soir vous pilotez
les députés communistes à l'Assemblée
vous êtes une voix députés communiste et
d'outre mère prcise c'est vrai c'est
important de le souligner vous êtes une
voix forte et singulière au sein de la
nup en proie de profonde division on va
en parler tout à l'heure vous venez
aussi nous parler de votre dernier livre
sur Cuba Cuba une île une étoile pardon
dans la nuit aux éditions Le Temps des
sereries c'est un plaidoyer pour la
levée du blocus américain sur lîle on va
en parler longuement tous les deux tout
à l'heure notre grand débat ce soir
faut-il supprimer l'aide médicale d'État
c'est l'autre point d'achopement avec la
droite sur le projet de loi sur
l'immigration les soins médicaux pour
les sans papiers géralde Darmanin veut
les restreindre aux soins d'urgence le
sujet divise jusque dans les rangs de la
majorité on en débat dans un tout petit
instant sur ce plateau avec mes invités
enfin nos afanchi ce soir le billet écho
d'Olivier babo une nouvelle histoire
d'école avec Yanis roder et puis Bourbon
Express bien sûr signé Marco pommier
voilà pour le menu on y va André chassig
bien ça vous regarde ça commence
[Musique]
maintenant c'est l'autre caillou dans la
chaussure du gouvernement la réforme de
l'aide médicale d'État elle ne figure
pas dans le projet de loi du
gouvernement sur l'immigration mais la
droite notamment au Sénat veut la
réformer alors pourquoi faire comment et
est-ce bien utile bonsoir Stella Dupont
bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes député
renessence du menéloir membre de l'aile
gauche de la majorité je précise que
vous êtes opposé à la suppression de
l'aide médicale d'État contrairement à
vous Véronique louvagi bonsoir députés
les républicains de l'Orne et tout comme
vous vous voulez cette suppression
Johann Gillet bonsoir député
rassemblement national du gare
Jean-François Corti le vice-président de
Médecin du Monde qui a signé la tribune
de 3000 soignants dans le monde pour
maintenir cette aide va nous rejoindre
dans les minutes qui vienne inutile de
préciser André chass que vous intervenez
dans ce débat quand vous le souhaitez on
va commencer par planter le décor de
quoi parle-t-on quels sont les
conditions et qui peut prétendre à cette
aide c'est dans le chrono blacco bien
sûr tout de suite
et je me retourne comme chaque soir je
vous invite André chasseg à faire la
même chose pour écouter Stéphane
Blakowski alors laame ce soir bonsoir
mir bonsoir à toutes et tous et bien
vous le rappeliez myiam en fait le
projet de loi d'immigration de géralde
berin au départ ne prévoyait pas de
supprimer l'aide médicale d'État mais en
mars les sénateurs ont voté un
amendement qui justement vise à
supprimer la me pour la remplacé par une
aide médicale d'urgence donc ce qui
aurait pour effet de limiter l'accès aux
soins des des étrangers des étrangers
pardon en en situation irrégulière donc
l'initiative vient des républicains qui
s'inquièteent puisque depuis sa création
il y a une vingtaine d'années vous voyez
que le nombre de bénéficiaires de cette
aide médicale d'État a plus que doublé
donc ça a un cût ça coûte plus d'un
milliards par an ce qui est une somme
très importante mais qu'on peut
relativiser quand on sait que ça ne
correspond qu'à 0,5 % de l'ensemble des
dépenses de santé cela dit les sénateurs
républicains sont très constants sur le
sujet et ça date pas d'hier regardez
c'était il y a déjà 4 ans et bien Bruno
rotillo était déjà sur le sujet on
écoute et au Sénat tous les ans nous
votons la mu vous voulez transformer
l'aide médicale d'État en aide médicale
d'urgenceence pour les maladies
contagieuses les maladies infectieuses
mais on ne peut pas ouvrir à toute la
misère du monde le le droit aux soins
résultat comme Gérald d'armmanin ben
aimerait bien compter sur le vote des
républicain pour faire adopter son
projet de loi immigration regardez
c'était début octobre dans Le Parisien
dans une grande interview il a dit qu'à
titre personnel lui bah il était
d'accord avec les républicains il était
prêt à supprimer cette aide médicale
d'État pour la remplacer pour par une
aide d'urgence le problème c'est qu'en
cherchant à plaire aux républicains bah
il risque de se fâcher avec sa majorité
ça ce sont les tribunes qui ont été
publiés dans la presse donc en juin
c'était 25 députés Renaissance dont vous
faisiez partie qui rappellent leur
attachement à l' puis hier c'était les
députés modemes à peu près aussi
nombreux qui eux aussi allaient dans le
même sens et alors là où ça se complique
encore d'un cran c'est que même au sein
du gouvernement tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord avec géralde daranin le premier
à le dire celui qui le dit le plus fort
c'est Olivier veréran en expliquant
notamment que si on on supprime cette
aide médicale d'État bien les gens vont
finir par aller se soigner aux urgences
quand ça sera déjà un peu trop tard et
que ça va coûter encore plus cher
finalement au budget de l'État et puis
autre argument contre les suppressions
elle a été notamment cet argument
rappelé dans cette tribune où 3000
personnes ont signé c'estàd que si on ne
soigne pas d'emblé des des gens atteint
d'une maladie contagieuse et bien le
risque c'est que la maladie se répande
dans l'ensemble de la société c'est
d'ailleurs un argument qui a repris
l'actuel ministre de la Santé Aurélien
Rousseau qu'on écoute et donc notamment
sur toutes les les pathologies
infectieuses il est évident que si la
médecine de ville n'est plus n'est plus
là euh ACC cours sur tuberculose
hépatite et cetera on va diffuser des
pathologies bref puisque le gouvernement
et la majorité sont divisés qui doit
prendre la décision et bien bien sûr la
première ministre alors histoire de pas
avoir l'air de décider toute seule c'est
couvert un peu en commandant un rapport
sur le sujet à deux personnalités une de
droite Patrick stéphanini une de gauche
claudvin et même si le rapport n'est pas
encore publié il y a déjà des fuites qui
sont parus dans la presse qui nous le
rapport dirait qu'en fait cette aide
médicale d'État ne constitue pas un
appel d'air ce qu'on appelle n'incite
pas spécialement les étrangers à viser
la France plutôt qu'un autre pays bon on
notera que en 2019 Édouard Philippe
avait commandé un autre rapport sur le
même sujet qui disait que il y avait
quand même des abus donc abus pas abus
en tout cas la première ministre elle
semble avoir pris sa décision sur le
sujet en l'écoute vous nêtes pas
favorable de d'une suppression de la me
non non je ne suis pas favorable à une
suppression de la me alors en press ça
on peut changer de nom mais le principe
qu'on peut-être soigné parce que ça
renvoie à un enjeu de santé publique je
pense qu'il est important dans notre
pays alors vous avez entendu elle ne
veut pas changer la me mais elle veut
bien changer de nom moi je sais pas si
on change de nom de la me c'est bien
qu'on veut aussi changer le contenu non
de la me enfin en tout cas on est là
pour en débattre merci c'était
parfaitement expliqué mon cher Stéphane
cétait là duupont pour vous c'est une
ligne rouge cette cette question de la
suppression de la me si elle était
finalement dans le texte vous voterez
contre l'ensemble du projet de loi alors
c'est surtout une constance c'est-à-dire
que l'aide médicale d'État au travers
les différentes interventions on on
comprend que c'est un sujet de santé
publique c'est-à-dire des étrangers
concernés bien entendu par l'accès aux
soins mais pour l'ensemble des Français
et d'ailleurs l'Espagne qui elle-même
avait supprimé l'aide médicale d'État en
2012 s'est rendu compte que en terme de
mortalité ou en terme de diffusion des
maladies contagieuses il y avait des
augmentation elle est donc revenue et
revenue à l'aide médicale d'État en 2018
et pourtant Gérald Darmanin est ouvert
alors qu'est-ce qu'il fait Géral Dar à
quoi jout-il il a indiqué que c'était
une décision personnelle et et voilà
c'est pas celle du gouvernement après
priori puisque la première ministre a
rappelé son attachement à l'aide
médicale d'État au sein de la majorité à
l'Assemblée nous sommes aussi très
nombreux à être attachés à cette à ce
dispositif vous avez aussi des collègues
je le précise dans votre groupe
renissance les maronistes qui sont pour
hein cette réform il y a il y a euh des
discussions mais je crois qu'on est
solidement ancré et attaché au texte
initial présenté par le gouvernement qui
ne parle pas et qui n'intervient pas sur
ce sujet de l'aide médicale et il y a
d'ailleurs la perspective peut-être d'un
cavalier législatif aussi pour pour ce
sujet intégré dans un tel texte on va
voir ça je salue l'arrivée de
Jean-François Corti bonsoir on est ravi
de vous accueillir vous êtes le
vice-président de de Médecin du Monde
vous avez signé cette tribune je le
disais dans le monde Je viens vers le
soignant que vous êtes on a même tourné
à médecin du monde ce matin dans un
instant je termine le tour de table
politique Véronique louvagi vous avez
fait vous un rapport au sein de la
commission des finances sur l'aide
médicale d'État 1,2 milliards par an le
rapporteur du budget dit que c'est le
milliard le mieux géré le mieux dépensé
parce qu'il est il est clair on sait à
quoi il sert il est il est utide vous
dites qu' il est mal dépensé cet argent
pourquoi je je ce que nous pouvons dire
c'est que nous avons une croissance
significative du nombre de bénéficiaires
et aujourd'hui une absence de pilotage
de ces crédits budgétaires c'est une
augmentation de 3 33 % depuis 2017 donc
c'est quand même important le nombre de
bénéf iciire sur ces 6 derniers mois a
augmenté de quasiment 20000 et le nombre
d'entrées de nouveaux bénéficiaires de
l'aide médicale d'État sur le premier
trimestre 2023 c'est plus de 55000 c'est
9000 de plus que le même nombre de
nouveaux entrés sur le même trimestre
202 pour vous il y a une forme de quoi
de de de médecine de complaisance de
tourisme médical ce sont les expressions
qu' qu'on peut dire de gens qui viennent
uniquement pour avoir accès à ces soinsl
ça alors je regrette le manque de
données demande de transparence sur ces
données je demande depuis 2017 je suis
rapporteur spécial de la mission santé
qui qui est consacrée à ces crédit
crédit budgétaire de l'aide médicale
d'État je demande depuis 2017 à avoir la
nationalité des bénéficiaires de l'aide
médicale d'État et d'ailleurs la
Défenseur des droits elle-même demande
cette disposition parce que elle elle le
dit de cette manière là cette absence de
données permet tous les fantasmes et
empêche de réfléchir sereinement voilà
effectivement dans ce nombre de
bénéficiaires nous ne savons pas pas si
ces bénéficiaires sont entrés de manière
irrégulière en France ou si ces
personnes sont entrées de manière
régulière et sont resté après une fois
que leur titre de séjour a expiré voilà
et donc moi je demande toutes ces
données j' d'ailleurs peut-être qu'il
faut les données avant de légiférer
peut-être mieux mais mais moi jepir
comment légiférer je dépose un
amendement chaque année pour obtenir ces
données ces données par exemple existent
pour les demandeurs de droits d'asile
nous connaissons la nationalité de donc
un manque de transparence qui vous fait
si je comprends bien plutôt suspecter un
certain nombre d'abus c'est ça la
positionouou des abus il y en a mais il
n'y a pas que des abus et je voudrais
juste préciser que je ne demande pas la
suppression de l'aide médicale d'État je
crois que c'est important je demande la
transformation avec une restriction du
panier de soins à l'instard de ce qui se
fait dans les autres pays européens je
rappelle et d'ailleurs cela a été
signalé que en 2019 un rapport conjoint
de l'IGAS et de l'IGF avait indiqué que
nous avions le système le plus généreux
d'European g il y a 400000 bénéficiaire
de l'Ame en France pour vous c'est
400000 de trop c'est ça la position du
rassemblement national nous notre
position elle est très claire depuis des
années nous sommes pour la suppression
de la me pour le remplacer par l'Aide
médicale d'urgence c'est ce que nous
proposons depuis plus de 15 ans
d'ailleurs je me félicite que les
républicains aujourd'hui soit sur la
même ligne que nous alors
M alors même qu'ils n'ont pas voté et en
2018 et en 2016 donc sur deux mandats
différents justement cette suppression
de la me transformé en en aide médicale
d'urgence donc je me félicite que les
républicains évoluent ils se sont
trompés dans le passé ils se sont
finalement rendu compte qu'ils avaient
tort et maintenant ils changent la vie
tant mieux c'est souvent le cas pour les
républicains sur cette loi immigration
d'ailleurs c'est le cas régulièrement
puisque on peut aussi faire le parallèle
avec l'article 3 pour la régularisation
des clandestin où les sénateurs les
républicains en commission des Lois du
Sénat ont voté pour l'article 3 c'est
quoi l'urgence parce que on peut retirer
des des soins dans un panier défini dans
un décret mais dire qu'on reste sur
l'urgence rclurence qui c'est qui juge
de l'urgence c'est ça se passe à
l'hôpital l'urgence c'est l'urgence
vitale y a-t-il urgence vitale ou non le
le le le principe il est simple c'est
une pompe aspirante parmi tant d'autres
ça participe à
l'attractivité de de la France pour des
clandestins c'est pas la seule pompe
aspirante il y a plein d'autres mais
tout ça mis bout à bout et bien fait que
l'on devient un
territoirezemples concr ben concrètement
oui vous avez beaucoup de clanstin de
personnes qui choisissent quel type de
soin pour venir en France non qui
choisissent la France parce que la
France et reconnu de tous et de toutes
les études a une capacité à être
généreuse avec celle ceux qui viennent
sur le territoire illégalement que ce
soit en matière donc de santé que ce
soit en matière et bien financière au
quotidien de logement également la
France est généreuse et trop généreuse
et d'ailleurs vous dites il y a 400000
clandestins qui bénéficient de laame il
faut rappeler également qu'il y en a
trois fois plus qui pourrai y prétendre
là aussi il y a un risque il y a un
risque à la fois pour les fin 50 % de
non recours hein il faut l'exliquer
cette aide elle n'est même pas connu des
il faut Rapp con et il faut rappeler que
un tiers des Français renonc aujourd'hui
à des soins faute de moyens comment
est-ce qu'on peut se regarder en face
quand on a des Français qui cotisent qui
eux ne peuvent pas se soigner alors même
que des personnes qui sont en situation
irrégulière bénéficient de ce dispositif
alors Jean-François Corti vous qui êtes
soignant comment vous regardez ce débat
on va voir un reportage pour voir
comment Médecin du Monde accompagne dans
les démarches les personnes concernées
mais déjà est-ce que vous êtes choqué en
tant que médecin par ce débat ou pas je
les éléments qui sont avé notamment en
matière de santé publique pour
distinguer l'urgence vitale de l'urgence
pas vitale ne tiennent pas selon le
stade d'évolution d'une maladie à un
moment donné elle sera pas mortelle et
puis 6 mois après si vous la prenez pas
en charge elle sera mortelle donc
médicalement ça tient pas à ce
raisonnement je suis désolé mais c'est
comme ça la manière que on évoquait le
taux de non recours qui est à 50 % et
dans les centres de santé de Médecin du
Monde c'est 2 tiers des personnes qui
viennent qui pourrait mériter l'aide mit
d'État mais qui ne l'ont pas parce
qu'ils savent pas que ça existe c'est
compliqué il y a la barrière de la
langue il a la fracture numérique et
donc il y a pas un phénomène d'appel
d'air en lien avec l'idée de venir
profiter des droits sociaux en France et
en Europe ça c'est une vue de l'esprit
c'est pas ça dans la grand les
rinoplasties les les anos
gastriques nexiste pas panier de soin il
a déjà été suffisamment réduit pour
qu'on soit sur une approche où il y ait
pas d'abus genre euh aller en sur des
cures thermales faire la chirurgie
esthétique ou avoir des implants
auditifs ou autres même si des implants
auditifs à un moment donné ça peut être
utile donc le panier de soin il est
assez bien calibré et toutes les études
montrent sérieusement qu'il y a pas
d'abus plus que sur d'autres dispositifs
dont tous les Français peuvent bénéficer
donc on voit bien et c'est ça qui est
assez étonnant c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
d'éléments rationnels qui sont mis en
avant pour valoriser laame comme un
dispositif de santé publique euh qui est
utile à la société aux personnes en
situation administrative précaire mais
aussi aux Français et je pense qu'il
faut le dire en fait il faut dire à nos
concitoyen que lorsque vous attaquez
laame pour mettre en question l'accès
aux soins les plus précaires ok c'est un
droit ment les son papier mais vous
mettez en danger la santé de tous et de
nos concitoyens pourquoi parce qu'il y a
un principe de santé publique qui est
important qui a rien à voir que la
solidarité ou une vision idéologique
d'accord il y a un principe de santé
publique qui dit que plus l'écart de
santé est important et plus inégalités
de santé sont importantes au sein d'
Maine société et plus l'état de santé
global de la société sera mauvais donc
lorsque vous empêchez des personnes en
situation administrative précaire de se
so soigner de manière précoce non
seulement vous impactez les C à
l'hôpital parce que les soignants ils
sont encore sur sur laproch
d'Hippocrate ils vont soigner les gens
vous empêchez vous saturez les les les
les hôpitaux vous faites en sorte qu'on
fait perdre le bénéfice contuc meilleure
prise en charge médicale non et
simplement il faut le dire et ça met en
danger la vie de nos concitoyens c'est
ça qui c'est ça qu'il faut que les
détracteurs de l'aide médicale d'État
assum médicétat c'est mettre en danger
les Français qu'est-ce que vous répondez
au rassemblement national pas la
caricature c'est de la santé publque
c'est une caricature parce qu'en réalité
c'est une mesure c'est une mesure qui
n'est pas prendre de manière isolée on
parle là de personnes en situation
irrégulière sur le territoire national
donc la première d'ailleurs des mesures
c'est de faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait
plus de personnes qui soient en
situation irrégulière sur le territoire
national mais non c'est courage
politique et de la volonté
politique on n'aura pas demain zéro
immigration illégale je suis bien
d'accord avec vous mais si on la
limitait au maximum et bien cela
permettrait finalement que ce sujet n'en
soit plus un parce qu'on aurait
finalement un nombre assez insignifiant
de personnes situation irrégulière sur
le territoire et dans ce cas-là il n'y
aurait pas ce problème dux pour la santé
c'est une incitation à venir c'est ce
que vous dites qu'est-ce que vous
répondz là-dessus ce fameuse argument de
l'appel d' et ensuite on regarde le
reportage je suis extrêmement choqué en
terme d'humanité bon il y a tous les
arguments qui sont les arguments
médicaux qui disent que c'est
contreproductif je vais pas revenir
là-dessus c'est pas mon rôle de de
développer ça les médecins le
développent très bien mais c'est une
question d'humanité le droit à la santé
est un droit qu'on doit respecter et et
qu'on dise on va ne pas soigner des
personnes parce qu'elles sont ici sur
notre sol de façon illégale je n'admets
pas ça je n'admets pas moi
personnellement ça ça me choque
énormément on puisse considérer que des
personnes puissent rester mourir chez
elles ou parce que il y a le
réchauffement climatique parce que des
problèmes de guerre qui quelquefois sont
déclarés par sont déclenchés par
nous-mêmes et que parce qu'elles sont
chez nous avec de façon illégal que sont
pas de titre de séjour on ne devrait pas
les soigner on ne devrait pas les
soigner inacceptable que vos collègues
des républicains majoritaires au Sénat
viennent d'adopter cet amendement donc
déposé par par la droite sur la
suppression la transformation de l'aide
médicale d'État comment ça se passe sur
le terrain est-ce que les personnes
concernées s'inquiètent déjà de cette
possible suppression c'est un reportage
d'éèine Bonduel et ivanavion qui sont
allés voir d'ailleurs vos équipes
jean-fançois Corti de Médecin du Monde
reportage la plupart sont étrangers
titre de séjour arrivé en France il y a
peu et ont besoin de soins
médicaux ce matin ils suivent un atelier
dirigé par un bénévole pour pouvoir
prétendre à l'AME l'aide médicale d'État
ça vous permet d'aller voir un médecin
qui accepte de prendre laame qui pourra
vous faire une ordonnance pour des
médicaments vous pourvez aller chercher
à la pharmacie dans les deux cas vous ne
prez pas si vous devez faire une
prothèse dedans ou les lunettes ou les
ou les des appareils pour entendre
ça c'est pas remboursé comme enfin il y
aura des choses à payer de votre poche
Marinova bulgare est venu demander la me
pour son compagnon mexicain en France
depuis 10 ans sans aucune couverture
médicale je ici pour aller les médecins
pour faire les radiographies les malades
dans les pieds très grave et c'est pour
ça nous beso orthopédi il n'y a pas de
doigt sinon nous beso de payer c'est
cher nous il n'y a pas de d'argent
d'argent de payer ça l'échographie de
Loué c'est
309 pour prétendre à l'AME il faut être
en situation irrégulière prouver sa
présence sur le territoire français
depuis 3 mois et avoir moins de 810 € de
ressources par mois les ressortissants
étrangers peuvent alors remplir ce
formulaire c'est assez
compliqué déjà faut parler français et
ça c'est un obstacle important pour
beaucoup de gens qui ne par pas français
ou qui ne sont pas suffisamment à l'aise
en français pour le remplir on sait
qu'il y a des gens qui renoncent il y a
des enquêtes qui ont été
fait qui démontre que environ la moitié
des gens qui ont droit à la renonce
n'engage pas les démarches tellement
elles sont compliquées ce jour-là à la
permanence de Médecin du Monde c'est un
ressortissant pakistanais qui s'inquiète
de l'obtention de son
ame alors monsieur a entendu parler
d'une loi peut-être qui va passer au
Parlement et qui
va tant qu'elle n'est pas passé ou voter
ou ou imposé par manière ou une autre on
ne sait pas pour le moment l'ame
s'applique actuellement un peu plus de
40000 personnes bénéficient de
l'Ame Véronique louvagie quand on voit
ce
reportage on se dit que ce serait
peut-être une erreur de santé publique
majeure de de ne pas continuer les soins
d'autant que et vous le savez vous tous
les députés ce panier de soins il a déjà
été restreint par Édouard Philippe en
2019 qu'est-ce qu'on a enlevé et
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait enlever de plus
alors qu'on on se rend compte que on est
tous un peu concernés parce qu'il y a
des problèmes de santé publique qui
concernent et qui peuvent se propager de
de maladies et autres alors le le panier
de soins ressemble sensiblement à notre
panier de soins ont été enlevés les
cures thermales tout ce qui concerne la
la PMA et et quelques actes de biologie
et quelques médicaments mais très peu
c'est vraiment un panier de soins qui
ressemble au au panier de soins que nous
pouvons avoir nous avons aujourd'hui une
explosion du nombre de bénéficiaires les
bénéficiaires de laame restent en
moyenne 3,6 année dans le dispositif ame
est-ce que c'est normal que nous ayons
des personnes en situation irrégulière
qui restent dans notre pays autant
d'années sous le régime de l'aide
médicale d'État je crois que c'est une
vraie question et et nous avons des
dépenses aujourd'hui qui augmentent
j'ajoute à cela que il n'existe pas que
le dispositif de l'aide médicale d'État
concernant les personnes en situation
irrégulière il y a 10 autres dispositifs
il y a par exemple le dispositif du
droit d'asile aujourd'hui un demandeur
de droit d'asile même s'il émane d'un
pays d'origine sûre c'est-à-dire un pays
dans lesquels il n'y a pas de difficulté
de de droit de l'homme de souci
démocratique pendant les 3o premiers
mois où cette personne làà est en France
elle est prise sous un dispositif d'ame
de soins urgents en ensuite le temps de
l'examen de la demande c'est pas la même
chose de elle est même ensuite elle est
prise sous le dispositif Puma le temps
de l'examen de la demande d'asile qui
peut durer de 12 à 24 mois c'est-à-dire
le dispositif protection universelle
maladie ensuite à l'expiration de de
enfin lorsque la demande d'asile est
examinée si la personne bénéficie de la
demande d'asile elle bénéficie de
dispositif Puma et c'est très bien parce
que notre pays doit être généreux et et
accueillant vis-à-vis de ces person en
revanche si la demande d'asile n'est pas
accordée à cette personne pendant 7 mois
et demi cette personne reste sous un
dispositif Puma c'est-à-dire un
dispositif de santé comme vous vous
voulez pas supprimer ce dispositif Puma
et ensuite et ensuite elle elle si elle
reste en France elle elle est
sous et aujourd'hui nous avons des
personnes qui demandent l'asile pour
obtenir ce type de soin et moi je
demandais à ce que les personnes qui
émanent d'origine de de de pays
d'origine sûre ne puisse pas bénéficier
d'un dispositif plus Mar il faut ré
c'était là duupont en fait
l'accumulation des dispositifs permet de
rester plus longtemps en France et donc
d'avoir les bénéfices de cette aide
médicale d'État plus longtemps moi je je
crois que la France n'est pas la plus
attractive et n'est pas plus attractive
l'Allemagne par exemple attire beaucoup
plus d'étrangers que la France il faut
arrêter avec ces ces idées préconçues
qui ne sont correspondent pas à la
réalité quant à l'envolé du du nombre de
bénéficiaires ou d' une dérive
financière de l'aide médicale d'État ça
représente moins de 0,5 % des dépenses
de santé de notre pays des sondages ont
été frit auprès des Français et
lorsqu'on leur explique ce qu'est cette
aide médicale destat comme le médecin
vient de nous l'expliquer à l'instant il
ils sont favorables à cette mesure ils
comprennent l'enjeu de santé publique
moi je crois que derrière cette ce
chiffon rouge en définitive de l'aide
médicale d'État il y a une volonté
d'instrumentalisation du sujet des
étrangers dans notre pays et que c'est
ça le fond du sujet et c'est pour cette
raison exactement que je suis contre le
fait qu'on supprime cette tê médicale
d'État le fond est là a été rappelé en
terme de santé publique la réalité de de
du besoin de nos concitoyens elle est
essentielle et les Français comprennent
cette mesure et la soutiennent donc pour
moi tout est dit après c'est c'est de la
gesticulation politique et on ne doit
pas tomber dans ce piège tout simplement
enfin la la droite et le et le RN assume
complètement de vouloir restreindre
l'immigration par ailleurs d'
pour répondre et pour répondre à la
question du nombre et de la durée
effectivement dans cette mesure il y a
des gens qui travaillent dans notre pays
qui peuvent être là présents depuis
plusieurs années et qui ne sont pas en
situation régulière il y a des mesures
pour régulariser leurs permettre de
rester dans notre pays notamment
lorsqu'ils occupent des métiers en
tention ça permettra de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait moins de gens bénéficiires
de l'aide médicale d'État ça c'est
l'article 3 dont on sait à quel point il
suscite des polémiques Jean-François cor
tous les éléments sanitaires de santé
publique R montre qu'il y a un intérêt
on l'a rappelé de soigner précocément
des personnes avec un panier de soins
qui est qui est bien régulé mais nos
voisins font la même chose il y a une
attractivité on Rapp en Espagne mais non
il y a pas y a la grande majorité des
gens ne ment pas parce que il y a laame
en France il m pour d'autres raisons
qu'on a rappelé d'insécurité ou autre
c'est pas le sujet ce que je veux dire
c'est que tous les éléments rationnels
vont dans le sens de la préservation de
ce dispositif dès lors qu'on s'intéresse
à la santé des personnes en situation
administrative précaire et des Français
je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure mais ce
que je veux dire c'est quand on parle
d'un budget de 0,4 % et qu'on laisse
croire au 15 % de la population
française qui vit sous le seul pauvreté
que c'est avec 0,4 % euh qu'on va du
budget qu'on va répondre aux enjeux de
fond de lutte contre la pauvreté que
sont le prix des mutuels que sont les
difficultés d'accéder à un travail euh
c'est c'est c'est leur mentir en fait il
faut travailler sur les questions
d'inégalité de manière profonde mais
c'est pas en instrumentalisant la
question des plus précaires et au fr
c'est une certaine lâcheté encore une
fois de s'attaquer au plus précaire sur
un budget 04 % qui est pas négligeable
je le conçois mais on pourrait réfléchir
si on veut faire des économie on va
réfléchir sur le prix des médicaments
sur le manque de transparence par
rapport au coût de certains traitements
enfin il y a plein de niches où on
pourrait faire beaucoup
d'économie je termine par là c'est
encore c'est c'est une manœuvre assez
assez lâche en fait de s'attaquer au
plus précaire et ça va contre les
intérêts de la santé publique et de nos
concitoyens l'un n'empêche pas l'autre
moi je suis stupéfait de voir à quel
point C ont une capacité à fermer les
yeux et à ne pas voir la réalité et à
dire vous mentez aux français quand on
vous leur dire allez répondre à leurs
besoins et la lutte contre les
inégalités c'est un mensonge fr vous
parlez d'un milliard 2 mais à c un
milliard 2 s'ajoute les montants du
dispositif Puma à C 1 milliard d'
s'ajoute tous les dispositifs faits pour
les personnes clandestines sur notre
territoire je rappelle que l'immigration
en France coûte en fonction des études
entre 35 et 41 milliards d'euros par an
plus
mais non je vous parle en coup non non
je vous parle en coup c'est un rapport
41 milliards c'est un rapport de
Matignon qui a été commandé par madame
la Première ministre c'est un rapport
officiel on ne peut pas dire qu'il émane
du rassemblement national en
l'occurrence c'est un rapport qui a été
présenté
parabthur petite question si on
supprimait la me pour en faire une aide
d'urgence l'hôpital serait forcément le
reportage que vous venez de montrer
parce que je pense qu'il faut prendre
l'exemple du reportage que vous avez
montré qui est relativement bien fait on
a ce monsieur d'origine mexicaine si je
me souviens bien qui est là depuis 10
ans et qui peut prétendre à la me mais
que fait-il en France depuis 10 ans il
peut prétendre à laame ça veut dire
qu'il ne travaille pas donc qu'est-ce
qu'il fait en France sans travailler en
ne respectant pas les lois de la
République en étant sur le territoire
national je suis désolé c'est pas
acceptable et on ne peut pas dire
également parce qu'on a parlé des
demandeurs d'asile qu'il n'y a pas de
demandeurs d'asile qui viennent en
France juste pour pouvoir bénéficier de
soins médicaux c'est une
réalitéé cet amendement était voté ce
qui n'est pas du tout sûr hein et je
rappelle que ça n'est pas la position du
du gouvernement en tout cas pas du
ministre de la Santé vous vous craignez
un déversement sur sur l'hôpital ou sur
les associations comme Médecin du Monde
si ces personnes ne pouvaient pas être
pris en charge par la me l'hôpital il
est déjà saturé on l'a déjà dit donc
c'est pas en supprimant la me qu'on va
améliorer cette mesure là simplement on
a fait un sondage avec le CSA qui vient
de sortir en interrogeant les Français
sur ce qu'il pensaient de la me quand
ils sont pas informés et ensuite en les
informant de ce que c'est ou par différ
résultat 60 % des Français sont pas
contre parce qu'ils ont bien compris
manifestement pas tout le monde mais en
tout cas les Français ont bien compris
qu'il y avait un intérêt pour eux que
laame reste en place et si on leur
explique c'est quoi laame pour qui dans
quelles conditions alors c'est 70 % y
compris des personnes qui sont à droite
c'est un c'est c'est un sondage c'est
pour ça qu'on essaie de faire de la
pédagogie quand on est sur l'éducatif
quand on donne des arguments et bien les
choses vont dans dans le bon sens et les
Français ils comprennent
parfaitement allez Véronique louvagi et
puis le mot de la fin question la
méthode des sciences c'est le CSA c'est
r j'avais eu le privilège de défendre
une proposition de
résolution en en juin dernier à
l'Assemblée nationale et je sais que
j'avais été interpellé par un grand
nombre de mes collègues de différents
groupes y compris de la la majorité sur
effectivement le besoin de transparence
que nous avons sur ces données ça peut
être un point d'accord sur
lequelbat éta avait en tout cas mis en
doute l'évaluation que j'avais fait des
1,8 milliards des 11 dispositifs qui
avaient été pour la première fois évalué
et et mis en avant et dire il y a un
sujet voilà et et la vraie difficulté
c'est que pour aborder cette question
nous avons besoin
déb et calme et ça n'est pas facile
sur un recentrage du panier de soin donc
une médicale d'urgence alors après il
faut le calibrer le débat commence au
Sénat il arrive à l'Assemblée d'ici
décembre on aura l'occasion d'y revenir
mais vous avez pu exposer vos vos
arguments je vous remercie on s'arrête
là merci beaucoup au députés à
Jean-François Corti d'être venu débattre
en direct vous restez avec moi André
chassegne dans une dizaine de minutes
les parties prix de nos affranchis ce
soir l'économie avec Olivier babo qui
revient sur la grande panne tricolore
sur la productivité Yanis roder de la
difficulté des profs quand les
politiques eux-mêmes maltraitent des
mots sur le conflit entre Israël et le
ramas et puis de quoi nous parlez-vous
ce soir dans Bourbon Express Marco Marco
Pomier et bien ce soir je vous parle de
Raquel garideau une insoumise trop
insoumise merci les amis à tout de suite
mais d'abord on va parler de votre livre
André chasseng Cuba une étoile dans la
nuit aux éditions Le Temps des sereries
c'est un essai dans lequel l'ami de Cuba
que vous êtes c'est comme ça que vous
vous assumez que vous présentez et bien
s'interroge à la fois sur le régime mais
surtout sur le blocus américain établi
par par Donald Trump sur l'île regardez
c'est dans l'invitation de ma Frémont et
on on en s'entretient juste
après si on vous invite André chassig
c'est parce que vous venez au secours
d'un des derniers régimes communistes de
la planète Cuba une étoile dans la nuit
écrivez-vous un livre comme un cri du
cœur pour interpeller les consciences
contre un blocus criminel à vos yeux et
aux yeux d'une écrasante majorité des
pays de l'ONU qui ont eux aussi demander
cette levée d'embargo américain il y a
tout juste 5 jours l'objectif c'est
d'affamer et se dire il n'est pas
possible d'avoir un régime socialiste
qui puisse faire vivre un peuple et que
partout dans le monde où il y a un tel
régime en court à la catastrophe vous
dressez le portrait sans concession d'un
Cuba exang dans la pire situation
économique de son histoire avec pour
vous deux responsables le blocus
américain et le covid qui a ruiné le
tourisme la principale ressource de ce
pays mais vous n'êtes pas très critique
avec le régime en place il faut dire que
votre attachement à Cuba ne date pas
d'hier oh là là là ça devait être
1968 ça c'était ma chambre chez Gevara
et puis derrière j'avais fait un montage
il y avait Lénine il devit y avoir
peut-être Mao
Marx fidèle Castro j'étais quand même
moins épais que maintenant depuis cette
photo l'auvernia que vous êtes est
devenu député 21 ans que vous fréquentez
les bands de l'hémicycle devenu
président du groupe communiste vous y
êtes également à la tête du groupe
d'amitié France Cuba à l'Assemblée
nationale votre fran- pararler raisonne
et même au sein de votre alliance nupè
vous savez vous démarquer comme ici
durant la réforme des retraites où il y
avait déjà des étincelles dans votre
mariage avec la France insoumise le
débat des mocque c'est un échange d'idée
c'est pas un échange
d'insulte dans votre ouvrage une
citation de Jean-Paul Sart a retenu
notre attention André chassigne en 1960
le philosophe écrivait je viens chercher
à Cuba la preuve que nous avons encore
une chance alors une question ce soir
pensez-vous qu'il soit encore possible
aujourd'hui de construire une société
communiste et
démocratique
alors la grande question la révolution
communiste est-elle compatible avec la
démocratie je le pense vraiment y
compris les les atteintes aux droits de
l'homme que l'on reproche à l'État
cubain aujourd'hui sont pour l'essentiel
la conséquence de l'asphixie qui est
l'asphixie de l'État cubain du peuple
cubain avec ce blocus ignoble et inconnu
on va en parler mais vraiment dire que
c'est exclusivement lié au blocus
après la
révolue on est quand même très très loin
d'une démocratie les droits de l'homme
sont pas respectés les opposants sont
arrêtés les élections ne sont pas libres
la presse non plus on manque de tout
desessens de pain d'eau en bouteille de
produits laitiers beaucoup de Cubains
rêve de partir et vous et vous en avez
rencontré il témoigne dans votre livre
n'est-ce pas la preuve d'une
incompatibilité non je pense qu'il y a
pas incompatibilité mais je pense qu'il
faut laisser la possibilité à un peuple
de créer son système politique sans
considérer que la seule possibilité
c'est un régime libéral c'est un régime
capital la démocratie c'est pas
forcément libéralismeoctie la démocratie
peut être liée à un système à un système
tel que le système cubain aujourd'hui il
vit des pires difficultés mais il y a
aussi une autre forme de démocratie
c'est vrai que il y a énormément de
réunions il y a la population qui est
concertée je ne dis pas qu'il faut un
parti unique comme c'est le cas à Cuba
on a dénoncé depuis suffisamment
longtemps le parti unique mais je pense
que la pensée unique quelquefois c'est
pas toujours aussi la bonne solution
donc il faut qu'il y ait une
comp moi je dirais qu'il faut un
bouillonnement démocratique je pense que
ce bouillonnement démocratique sous des
formes qu'on a des des difficultés
appréhender nous existe aujourd'hui à
Cuba amid Cuba ça veut dire quoi
précis ça veut dire que je choisis non
ça veut dire que je choisis mon côté de
la barricade comme disaient les atriolet
parce que je considère qu'à Cuba il y a
une révolution qui a été mené contre des
une dictature qui était en place et que
cette révolution aujourd'hui elle est
considérablement handicapée elle est
étouffé par le blocus américain et ça
c'est une réalité qu'il faut connaître
vient on y vient à ce blocus géant
l'assemblée générale des nations- Unies
c'est'est récemment exprimé de façon
complètement unanime pour la levée de ce
ce blocus sauf les États-Unis évidemment
qui s'y sont opposés avec Israël et
l'Ukraine qui s'est abstenu en quoi
consiste-t-il précisément donnez-nous
des des exemples des ravages qu'il
provoquent à Cuba très bien donc il faut
savoir que c'est parti d'un embargo dès
1960 où on a appliqué une loi de 197 en
disant qu'il devait plus y avoir de
commerce avec un pays et dememi alors
qu'il y avait pas de guerre entre Cuba
et les États-Unis ensuite il y a une
succession de loi la loi torichell
notamment en 1992 ensuite en 1996 il y a
eu la loi ELMS Burton tout est fait pour
qu'il a un blocus complet contre Cuba
quelques exemples quelques exemples ce
blocus il fait il fait qu'une entre
qui par exemple utilise plus de 10 % de
composantes américaines ce soit
technique ce soit financier n'a pas le
droit de commercer à Cuba c'est énorme
et donc elle elle est poursuivie ensuite
devant la justice américaine c'est
l'extraterritorialité exemple européen
ne peuvent pas actuellement c'est un
blocage complet c'est une asfixie du
carburant c'est bloqué donc ça crée
énormément les pièces de Rechar des
pièces de Rechar pour des tracteurs
c'est bloqué pour les locomotives c'est
bloqué un
qui décharge à Cuba n'a pas le droit
pendant 6 mois d'accosser sur les côtes
américain ça s'appelle l'extra
territorialité des lois du BL
c'est-à-dire que les les Américains donc
appliquent leur loi à l'ensemble de la
planète et poursuivent en justice toute
entreprise qui fait du commerce avec
Cuba donc c'est une une forme de de
prison à ciel ouvert pour vous c'est une
prison à ciel ouvert et je suis choqué
par le fait queil y a effectivement il y
a ces décisions de l'ONU contre le
blocus il y a seulement trois pays qui
n'ont pas voté cette proposition de
résolution pour la levée du blocus et
ben ça continue comme ça et en fait
c'est une espèce de mort lente et j'ai
honte qu'aujourd'hui on ferme les yeux
sur ce qui se passe à Cuba et sur le
rôle des États-Unis h mais en même temps
vous vous regardez aussi les difficultés
politique des
difficultés d'é de droit oui j'explique
aussi qu'il y a sans doute des lourdeurs
qui sont des lourdeurs bureaucratiques
il y a une réforme économique à Cuba
est-ce que vous pensez que le le blocus
se lèverait tout d'un coup la mis ch non
non mais je pense que ça permettra un
développement terrible aujourd'hui il y
a pas de possibilité l'entreprise
française peut pas s'installer à Cuba en
2015 Obama avait pourtant desserré les
taux Trump l'a resserré depuis et Biden
que fait Joe Biden Biden il fait rien
Biden il fait rien il y a eu
effectivement la remise en cause de
l'ouverture qui avait été faite par
Obama et il y a eu une bouffée d'oxygène
en quelque sorte et à l'arrivée de Trump
tout ça s'était renversé c'est pire que
ça c'est que c'est que Trump a inscrit
comme état terroriste Cuba et qu'à
partir de là ça ferme encore d'autres
perspectives commercial financière pour
Cuba alors que ça s'appuie sur
absolument rien du tout c'est une
volonté historique des États-Unis qui
est pas à 100 km de leur côte un régime
communiste oui après il y a la Floride
qui est un swing state qui bascule d'un
côté démocrate de l'autre républicain et
c'est là où tous les Cubains Américains
antiommunistes vivent aujourd'hui c'est
pour ça aussi euh que on est dans le
statut quo je pense qu'il y a ça ceci
étant dit en Floride il y a aussi
d'autres courants qui se développent qui
ne comprennent de moins en moins qui
puissent y avoir ce
blocus qui demande et qui d'ailleurs
depuis la Floride il y a les familles
d'exilés qui financec y compris des
entreprises qui se développent
aujourd'hui de façon privée à Cuba parce
qu'il y a une évolution du système
économique alors on va laisser un peu
Cuba cette et cette étoile dans la nuit
c'est le titre de votre livre un moment
on va revenir en France Fabien Roussel
le chef du parti communiste qui
d'ailleurs préface he votre livre estime
que la Nupe est dépassée je cite il dit
que c'est une impasse tout simplement et
pourtant bah le groupe communiste ici à
l'Assemblée les députés participent
toujours à cette à cette alliance à
l'intergroupe pourquoi pourquoi ne pas
la quitter clairement d' d'abord je
voudrais dire que je partage l'analyse
qui est faite par le Parti communiste
qui a été votée à 92 % par conseil
nation par le Conseil nation nationale
qui considère que la nuup c'est une
impasse je le pense aussi et qu'il faut
réfléchir à une un élargissement de la
gauche sur de nouvelle base ça je
partage cette analyse politique qui est
portée par le Parti communiste
jusgissement jusqu'à Bernard casenov sur
moi je vais pas citer de nom de Bernard
cas tout mais qu'on réfléchisse ensemble
si un jour on vaut être au gouvernement
et ben ça sera passera en étant recillé
sur nous-même comme c'est le cas avec
laanup ça c'est une première chose
ensuite je préside un groupe où il y a
12 députés communistes et 10 députés
d're m ce groupe c'est pas la voix du
Parti communiste c'est une réflexion qui
est une réflexion collective et qui fait
que on continue à travailler avec les
autres groupes de gauche l'intergroupe
ne se réunit plus d'ailleurs il se
réunit plus l'intergroupe depuis que les
socialistes se
sontc voilà l'intergroupe
pour l'intergroupe n'existe plus ils se
réunissaient tous les mardis matins il
se réunit pas mais nous pour autant on
considère qu'on doit travailler avec les
autres groupes de gauche c'est pas être
ficelé mais c'est dans le cadre de notre
de notre autonomie c'est ce que pensent
les écolos c'est ce que pensent les
socialistes et au sein de la France
insoumise il y a aussi beaucoup de
députés qui partagent ce point de vue il
y a un problème Jean-Luc Mélenchon
aujourd'hui au sein de la gauche pour la
gauche aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
c'est une ligne rouge qu'il l'a franchi
le chef des insoumis en en refusant de
qualifier le ramasse de groupe
terroriste je sais pas si c'est une
ligne rouge mais je crois que c'est une
énorme maladresse parce malad non c'est
c'est c'est inacceptable pour moi c'est
inaccept parce que c'est un acte
terroriste et on ne peut pas nier que
c'est un acte terroriste mais en plus de
ça c'est que ça empêche ensuite de
d'avoir une action positive pour arriver
à deux états un État palestinien un état
israélien comment voulez-vous qu'on
arrive à convaincre qu'on puisse
s'exprimer si on ne reconnaît pas le
massacre qui a été provoqué par amas il
a fait un certain nombre de tweets qui
ont été extrêmement comment dire
suspectés d'une forme d' imaginire un
peu antisémite je pense à celui sur Ron
Pivet celui sur le CRIF la défense de
jeréy corbin l'ancien leader
travailliste qui réactive une certaine
forme de de matrice d'imaginaire il y a
un problème avec avec les Juifs chez
Jean-Luc je pense que non enfin je je
vais pas me permettre d'apporter une
appréciation bien franchement je ne le
pense pas je ne le pense pas en tout cas
je l'espère pas après c'est à la France
insoumise en interne de pouvoir faire
émerger peut-être une autre approche et
de sortir du poids extrêmement écrasant
qui est celui de Jean-Luc Mélanchon ça
veut dire quoi ça le poids écrasant on a
l'impression je parle au communiste he
qui a connu aussi celui des années 50
avec c'est quoi c'est un fonctionnement
c'est un fonctionnement très pyramidal
avec le le leader en quelque sorte on le
voit d'ailleurs avec ce qui se passe au
sein du groupe de la France aujourd'hui
et je pense pas que ça soit ça soit une
bonne chose mais c'est à eux de régler
les affaires vous réagirez d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure à la chronique de Marco
Pomier sur les sanctions de Raquel
garido je voulais vous montrer quand
même un tweet de l'ambassadeur de Cuba
qui a pas vu qui a pas dû vous échapper
sur la guerre à Gaza d'Israël contre le
ramas en fait il a il a approuvé un
dessin on on va le voir ce dessin on le
voit à l'antenne le voilà ça c'est
l'ambassadeur de de Cuba qui dit
exactement et on montre un soldat de de
Sal avec ce ce brassard ce brassard nazi
inacceptable ça c'est Cuba ça si c'est
l'ambassadeur de Cuba en France je le
connais bien hein je lui dis que c'est
inacceptable d'avoir de relayer un tel
dessin qui ferait l'amalgame entre ce
qui étaient les nazis est- ce que sont
aujourd'hui les les combattants
d'Israël c'est inacceptable Catherine
colonab peut-être va va réagir et et lui
demander des des excuse l'explosion des
actes antisémites auquel on assiste en
France vous êtes surpris ou pas je suis
désespéré je pense que le Parti
communiste français a toujours toujours
lutté
contre cette façon de de s'attaquer aux
Juifs avec l'antisémitisme pour nous
c'est absolument inacceptable dans notre
ADN c'est pas quelque chose de
concevable et je je pense qu'il faut
lutter contre toute forme
d'antisémitisme comme d'ailleurs contre
comme toute forme de racisme alors une
manière peut-être de lutter contre cette
montée de l'antisémitisme c'est cette
marche dimanche initiative inédite à
l'appel des présidents du Parlement il a
elbrun Pivet pour l'Assemblée nationale
et Gérard Larcher pour le Sénat bonsoir
Elsa mondingava vous nous avez rejoint
parce que vous avez quelques petites
informations coulisses à nous donner sur
cette double initiative oui cette
tribune commune vous l'avez dit Myriam
un Yael Bron pivé présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale Gérard Larché
président du Sénat cette tribune elle
s'intitule pour une république et contre
l'antisémitisme marchons un peu plus
loin il est écrit plus qu'un sursaut
plus que des mots une mobilisation est
indispensable ce sera donc une grande
marche civique organisé ce dimanche
entre le Palais Bourbon ici l'Assemblée
et le Palais du Luxembourg le Sénat
cette idée elle s'est concrétisée hier
lors d'une rencontre entre Gérard
Larcher et yel brun pivé on le sait les
deux présidents s'entendent bien ils
voulaient tous les deux envoyer un
message fort leurs deux équipes ont
travaillé tard dans la nuit pour
parvenir à cette tribune ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'une manifestation et
bien ça se déclare en préfecture
l'organisateur dimanche ce sera
l'Assemblée nationale ça c'est assez
inédit he de mémoire de connaisseur sont
invités tous ceux qui se reconnaissent
dans les valeurs de notre République et
sont déterminés à les défendre
évidemment il y aura des membres du
gouvernement il y aura des députés de la
majorité ériic cotti président des
républicains a annoncé sa venue avant
même que la tribune ne paraisse Marine
Le Pen Jordane Bardella seront là
également les socialistes sont en train
de discuter de savoir s'ils viennent ou
pas les insoumis réservent encore leur
RP mais juste avant de rentrer en
plateau Jean-Luc Mélenchon a tweeté les
soutiens inconditionnels on massacre on
leur rendez-vous ce qui laisse peu de
doute sur la présence des ensoumis des
soutiens inconditionnels au Massac qu'on
le rendez-vous une réaction André chass
bon je pense que je vois pas pourquoi on
on ne participerait pas à cette
manifestation en ce qui concerne le les
députés de mon groupe j'en ai pas encore
discuté avec le groupe mais en ce qui me
concerne comme président ça me semble
naturel quand même dire que c'est un peu
regrettable que ça a été fait de cette
façon dans la mesure où c'est
l'Assemblée nationale en tant que tel
qui est organisatrice avec le Sénat C de
cette manifestation j'aurais préféré
qu'on réunisse les présidents de groupe
que ça soit un appel qui soit un appel
conjoint ça aurait je pense une autre
dimension que d'être uniquement un appel
de la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale et du président du Sénat ça
aurait davantage montré l'unité du pays
ENF en tout cas en ce qui me concerne je
vois pas pourquoi on ne par participerez
pas à cette manifestation allez vous
restez avec moi André chassign c'est
l'heure des affranchis vous allez réagir
à leur partie prix on les accueille tout
de suite Yanis roder professeur
d'histoire de la Fondation Jean jores et
Olivier babo de l'Institut sapience pour
l'économie installez-vous on commence
comme chaque soir par le bourbon Express
signé ce soir Marco Pomier de quoi nous
parlez-vous cher Marco bonsoir bonsoir
Miriam ce soir je vous raconte
l'histoire d'une punition qui passe mal
chez une partie de la France insoumise
Raquel garideau mise au banc ce sont ces
mots sanctionnés la nuit dernière par le
bureau de son propre groupe
parlementaire la députée de C saintny ne
pourra plus parler au nom des insoumis
pendant 4 mois plus de question
gouvernement plus d'explications de vote
on lui reproche une accumulation
d'agissement et de propos répétés qui
nuisent au bon fonctionnement du groupe
je cite alors a-t-elle critiqué trop
trop fort Jean-Luc Mélenchon ces
dernières semaines on écoute Antoine
léomand encore une fois je pense que
c'est sain que quand il y a des règles
collectives qui sont pas respectées il y
a une sanction qui soit associée surtout
quand ça fait beaucoup de fois qu'on a
essayé de dire les choses de manière
plus tranquille de régler les choses à
l'intérieur du groupe mais les insoumis
il y en a un certain nombre qui disent
que ça commençait à bien faire voilà
etquel garedo a très vite réagi oui he
la nuit dernière peu avant 1h du matin
sur X anciennement Twitter elle a
dénoncé le verdict de ce qu'elle appelle
la Cour Pénale insoumise ajoutant je
suis humilié en colère j'ai honte de
voir cette évolution du projet politique
auquel j'ai consacré 30 ans de ma vie et
cette sanction est loin de faire
l'unanimité au sein même des insoumis ou
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire les
frondeurs insoumis sont à nouveau sortis
du bois cette fois pour défendre Raquel
garido publiquement quel honte a dit
l'insoumise Daniel Simonet son collègue
François Ruffin vous le voyez lui se
demande avec ironie si la direction de
son groupe pourrait fournir la grille
tarifaire en cas de divergence politique
clémentinetin et Alexis Corbière ont
aussi réagi un grand mouvement comme le
nôtre il y a des désaccords politiques
stratégiques ne peut pas se régler par
des suspensions de quelques mois tu
parleras pas et cetera c'est dérisoire
c'est dérisoire et je suis aussi atterré
parce que 4 mois c'est exactement le
nombre de mois de la sanction qui a été
ordonnée contre notre collègue Adrien
catnins qui je le rappelle a été
condamné pour violence conjugale je
pense que symboliquement on on va dire
que c'est malheureux on va dire que
c'est malheureux mal heureux hein le
parallèle avec l'insoumis Adrien catnins
fait tâche pour les députés féministes
de gauche repost de Mathilde Panau ce
matin en conférence de presse la
présidente du groupe LFI a rappelé
qu'Adrien catnins avait été exclu du
groupe c'est pas le cas de Raquel garido
la sanction serait donc différente pas
identique bref sacrée ambiance Myriam
chez les insoumis dans le reste de la
nuupes et bien certains se satisfont
déjà de voir que les insoumis trop
insoumis deviennent majoritaires dans
leur groupe ça reste à ver
ça va durer combien de temps je me
satisfais pas je me désespère qu'il
puisse y avoir de telles décisions qui
sont prises envers une militante qui une
militante de la première heure la
première heure auprès de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est absolument incroyable
c'est et je je exprime toute ma
solidarité pour ma part j'ai prouve
aucune satisfaction à ce que ça se
produise je le regrette profondément et
je pense que c'est une image pitoyable
vous pensez qu'il y a une cission qui
est possible vous lui tendez la main à
quel gar il s'agit pas il s'agit pas de
de il s'agit pas de tendre la main il
s'agit de faire un constat après c'est
les députés de la France insoumis qui
peuvent entre décider de l'avenir de
leur groupe mais je pense pas qu'il soit
question aujourd'hui de fraction le
group pas critiquer en interme ça ça
s'appelle comment ça me rappelle
peut-être des époques que nous on a pu
effacer qui était un temps un parti ça a
été peut-être un temps au niveau du
Parti communiste quand on remonte dans
son histoire mais je crois que ça ça
nous a on a dépassé tout ça depuis
depuis très très longtemps depuis très
très longtemps et je trouve désespérant
cette sanction qui est prise contre
Raquel allez on va enchaîner avec la
chronique de Yanis roder vous vouliez
Yanis au lendemain de la rentrée
scolaire euh et bien lancer des
invitations à des hommes politiques à
nos élus de la République pour quelle
raison oui Miriam je avou que je suis un
peu fatigué fatigué d'entendre certains
élus pour parler qui pour parler du
conflit Israël Hamas utilise à tort et à
travers des mots et des concepts que mes
élèves de 14 15 ans semblent mieux
maîtriser je pense évidemment au termes
de génocide avancé par emerck Caron de
nettoyage ethnique utilisé par Mathilde
panot ou David guireud par exemple ou
encore quand Olivier fort parle de
discussion je cite pseudo intellectuel
quand Caroline Fourest essaie
d'introduire de la complexité c'estàdire
de faire réfléchir on a l'impression que
vous êtes même un peu en colère non oui
je suis en colère parce que nous passons
notre temps à expliquer aux élèves qu'il
faut utiliser les termes à bonécian le
rôle du prof c'est de revenir aux
définitions pour réfléchir échir sur les
événements pour les experts des Nations
Unies le nettoyage ethnique c'est une
politique délibérée visant à faire
disparaître d'une zone géographique par
le recours à la violence ou à la terreur
des populations civiles appartenant à
une communauté ethnique ou religieuse
malgré le degré de violence de la
réponse israélienne rien ne permet
objectivement de dire que c'est la
politique d'Israël à Gaza h quant au
terme de génocide alors là ça confine à
l'absurde la définition juridique et
historique du génocide répond à
l'intention d'assassiner
systématiquement d'exterminer une
population mais le fait que l'armée
israélienne demande préalable au civil
de quitter les zones qu'elle attaque
témoignerait plutôt du contraire quant
aux discussions pseudointtellectuelle
entre guillemets si la mort d'homme de
femme d'enfant est toujours une tragédie
ni les contextes ni les modalités des
attaques ne sont de même nature si les
souffrances se valent et je le répète si
les souffrances se valent les intentions
ne se valent pas les intentions du Hamas
étai de tuer le plus de civils possible
ce ne sont pas les intentions d'Israël
Quoi que certains disent ou pensent vous
croyez que ça change quelque chose sur
le le clim sur l'opinion de dire ça ou
les chux sont fait de mon point de vue
moralement ça change tout c'est ce qui
marque la différence entre un groupe
terroriste sanguinaire et une démocratie
or ces députés prisonniers excusez-moi
de leur vision simple dominer dominant
les gentil les méchants veulent
absolument mettre un signe égal entre
Israël et le Hamas en effaçant
volontairement ce qui les différencie
fondamentalement alors que l'école elle
cherche à apporter précision nuances
raison ces gens excite les passions et
alimente la haine à des fins
électoralistes en joant sur les émotions
est-ce que c'est là le rôle d'élu de la
nation peu importe d'ailleurs pour eux
que aujourd'hui l'antisémitisme dont ils
s fusqueront évidemment mett en danger
des citoyens français peu importe que 40
français éent été tués dans les tuories
du 7 octobre et que H soi encore a Tage
il faut raller des voix et la fin
justifie les moyens j'apprends tous les
ans vous savez Miriam à mes élèves la
fameuse phrase d'Albert Camu mal nommer
les choses s'est ajouté au malheur du
monde ces députés qui nous prennent
finalement pour des imbéciles devraient
y réfléchir car il nous précipite tous
au nom du bien qu'ils prétendent
défendre vers le pire merci beaucoup
pour ce parti prix Yanis roder les mots
l'importance du choix des mots pour
qualifier des faits et ne pas semer la
confusion y compris par les hommes
politiques vous souscrivez oui tout à
fait moi j'étais enseignant aussi
professeur d'histoire et et de lettrre
dans un collège et j'ai toujours eu
depuis une forme d'obsession de trouver
le mot juste parce que le mot il dit
beaucoup de choses et je renvoie souvent
un gramchi qui a donné un sens très fort
au langage et on peut détourner une
pensée idéologique en utilisant des mots
qui ne sont pas les mots appropriés et
je fais par exemple la différence entre
le gouvernement d'extrême droite
d'Israël et le peuple d'Israël parce que
si on fait une globalisation entre tout
ça c'est là qu'on ouvre la porte
notamment antisémitismez je suis très
très attaché à cette dimension d'essayer
de trouver le mot juste on termine avec
vous Olivier babo ce soir vous vouliez
tirer le signal d'alarme on est moins
productif nous en France gros coup de
pompe sur la productivité française oui
Miriam je vais aussi essayer d'avoir le
mot juste je n pas dit bonsoir ça y est
bonsoironsir vous la richesse d'un pays
elle dépend de quoi grosso modo quand
même de la quantité de travail qui est
fourni sans travail il y a pas de
revenus à taxer il y a pas de revenus à
dépenser il y a pas aussi de biens qui
ne seraiit pas importés c'est évidemment
catastrophique alors la quantité de
travail elle dépend de trois choses elle
dépend ben du nombre de travailleurs
total ce qu'on appelle la population
active occupée du nombre d'heures
travaillé par chacun d'eux évidemment et
puis surtout de la troisième chose qu'on
oublie parfois c'estàd la productivité
du travail les Français jusque-là
pouvaient se vanter d'avoir une
productivité très très bonne meilleur
que leurs voisins et donc certes c'est
vrai qu'on travaillit un petit peu moins
que les autres mais on était plus
efficace quand on se mettait à l'ouvrage
et donc ça compensait et ça c'est fini
c'est plus le cas c'est justement ça le
problème hélas non depuis 2019 notre
productivité recule donc ça fait quand
même 4 ans maintenant par rapport à
l'avant covid elle a reculé de 6 % alors
quelle est la cause de cette baisse de
la qualité de notre travail en fait on
on s'interroge l'économie s'interroge
première cause identifier il y a une
augmentation du nombre d'apprentissage
d'apprentis de gens en apprenti en
apprentissage ces Apprentiss sont moins
productifs d'abord parce qu'ils sont
plus jeunes mais surtout parce que
souvent ils étudient d'Illes c'est le
principe ils étudient en même temps et
donc la comptabilité fait que la
productivité baisse mais c'est une
première explicationè explication le
téléra
les gens avec le télétravil seraient
beaucoup plus loin de leur entreprise du
coup ils seraient démotivés ça colle pas
tout à fait avec les études qui montrent
que quand le télétravail n'est pas
supérieur à de jours par semaine on a
plutôt une productivité qui augmente
effectivement trop de télétravail tue en
particulier travail mais c'est pas la
bonne explication non plus troisème
cause le positionnement de notre
économie on a une économie qui est moins
industrielle là où il y a pourtant des
gaines de productivité qui sont plus
faciles et une économie qui est plus
intensive en main d'œuvre dans les
services là c'est plus dur de gagner de
la productivité enfin la
désindustrialisation désindustrialis B
oui parce qu'en fait il y a une 4è
explication qui est peut-être alors qui
est pas la explication majeure mais il
faut quand même la la citer c'est
peut-être une des plus convaincantes ce
sera un problème de motivation lui-même
lié à un problème de déficit de
management on a tous fait cette
expérience là en une heure de temps on
peut être soit être hyper productif soit
ne pas faire grand-chose d'ailleurs n
nos étudiants et nos élèves peuvent
aussi faire cette cette expérience et
malheureusement nous sommes assez
mauvais pour motiver les gens au travail
en tout cas si l'on en juge par le
nombre de jours d'absence au travail qui
est bien plus fort chez nous que chez
nos voisins on a a du mal à motiver
alors c'est un problème de management un
problème de formation des managers
peut-être de reconnaissance du mérite
peut-être de rapport au travail alors
pour conclure c'est vraiment un problème
décrochage de la productivité c'est pas
juste un problème technique parce que ça
revient à une augmentation du coût du
travail pour un même output si vous
voulez pour une même production ça
ralentit les augmentations de salaires
ça gonfle le prix de nos produits donc
c'est pas bon pour les exportations et
et notre pouvoir d'achat et c'est un
facteur de plus malheureusement on en
manquait pas d'appauvrissement relatif
vis-à-vis de nos voisins donc c'est
grave oui qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
essayer de de redonner je pense au
travail du sens son sens moi mon père
était ouvrier ouvrier Michelin
travaillait sur une
rectifieuse il allait au travail il
n'allait pas au travail à reculon il
avait une force de de disons de il
aimait son boulot quoi il était fier de
son travail et je crois que tout ça
petit à petit pour des raisons diverses
conditions de travail salaire regarde la
société aussi regarde la société quand
même
pasand reproch d'envoyer trop d'élèves
en formation technologique par exemple à
une époque où on pouvit aller préparer
un beep ensuite être en première
d'adaptation j'en ai même connu un
ancien élève qui est devenu docteur en
mécanique et donc il y a eu un regard
sur notamment sur les métiers manuels
qui a dévalorisé tout ça on est
pratiquement gêné aujourd'hui d'avoir un
métier manuel alors que c'est c'est la
noblesse ça pour pardon André chasseng
mais la gauche a un peu une
responsabilité la valeur travail vous
dit valoris oui oui c'est bien pour ça
que c'est d'ailleurs de façon peut-être
un peu on lui reproche d'être un peu
caricatural c'est ce que porte euh
Fabien Roussell Fabien Roussell he mais
on le porte peut-être mal à droite main
mais on voit bien qu'il faut redonner du
sens au travail et c'est par de
multiples raisons et je crois que votre
analyse elle est bonne enfin à mon avis
mais il y a pas seulement ça il y a
aussi presque une approche morale quoi
de considération du travail Olivier Bab
souvient du débat sur les retraites on
pouvait pas dire que la valeur travail
était à l'honneur hein euh on expliquait
que 2 ans de travail de plus c'était 2
ans de vie en moins quand on a comme ça
des chutes de productivité ça peut se se
retourner c'est des tend fait possible
c'est tout à fait possible il faut de la
motivation il faut de la formation ne
désespérons pas allez une note positive
pour terminer merci beaucoup les
affranchis en force ce soir et Merci à
VOUS André chassigne d'avoir été notre
grand témoin Cuba une étoile dans la
nuit un ami du Cuba mais de Cuba mais
pas forcément de de de son régime on va
résumer ça comme ça qui qui témoigne
merci à vous très belle soirée de entire
sur LCP avec Jean-Pierre Gratien à
[Musique]
demain